an entire generation of kids appear to
be suffering from a kind of mass
psychosis this seems like a problem that
deserves more attention than it's
getting also megalomaniac joe biden
brags that he's restored the soul of our
nation and merrick garland is asked why
he sent the fbi after parents at school
board meetings and his reason is less
than sufficient and how many undercover
feds were at the january 6 riots were
they the ones who encouraged the crowd
to enter the capital the evidence is
piling up we'll discuss all of that and
more today on the matt walsh show
[Applause]
[Music]
you know just because people are loud
and obnoxious it doesn't mean that
they're right in fact oftentimes it
works the other way around that's
certainly the case for quote-unquote
pro-choicers who are very loud very
relentless in all their talking points
but um they're also very wrong and but
sometimes because there's so many
talking points so many arguments they
throw you it can be hard to parse
through all of it and sift through it
and figure out what to say and when to
say it and that's one of the reasons why
i wrote the forward to the new book from
40 days for life what to say when the
complete new guide to discussing
abortion since its release it's already
been a number one amazon new release and
a number two amazon bestseller and it's
on its second printing because people
are finding that this book is very
helpful to them i know that that's how
it was for me the book is incredibly
easy to use it tells you what to say
what not to say and the proven arguments
that have worked for everybody people on
the fence abortion supporters even
planned parenthood workers 40 days for
life is the largest grassroots pro-life
organization in the world they're an
authority on this and you can trust them
and that's why you got to go to amazon
and get what to say when the complete
new guide to discussing abortion or you
go directly to 40 days for life at
40daysforlife.com
there's been a lot of talk about
pronouns this week first with the aclu
valiantly defending the loudoun county
school system's right to force teachers
to use the preferred pronouns of
students and then with the state
department urging us all to join in
celebrating international pronouns day
as i said yesterday it seems that it's
it's finally becoming apparent to most
people on the right
that this pronoun issue is not the
sideshow that um
many
once thought it was
i mean it is for one thing an attack on
our fundamental human liberties the
worst kind of attack in fact the problem
with the pronoun policy in loudoun
county and with similar policies that
are being adopted and will soon be
adopted in other localities around the
country it's not simply that speech is
being compelled
but specifically that false speech is
being compelled
i mean you can only have freedom real
freedom in truth
which is why any attack on real freedom
is also an attack on truth
these are the implications
and i think i hope
that that's now obvious to most people
on the right
but i also hope that anyone who was slow
on the uptake you know those who took a
while to understand the real threat that
all of this seemingly bizarre infringe
stuff poses to our society
i hope they won't make the same mistake
with the clips that i'm going to play
for you now because here we have two
more contributions to society from
tiktok both videos feature young people
teenagers
taking the preferred pronoun concept to
seemingly new extremes
in this first one we find out that some
of these kids are actually identifying
as inanimate objects listen
hello
i am doll
i am one of our object altars
when i front i find it very difficult to
remember things that the body requires
such as how to move
how to blink
how to breathe and how to speak
for the purpose of filming this video
i have meredith co-conscious with me
so that i will not mess up
however
this is the third take the first two
i forgot to breathe and or speak
i hope this helps you learn
now
doll here has not invented the doll
pronoun concept in fact a handy resource
is the website pronoun e dot xyz
which lists and explains all of the
different alternative pronouns currently
in existence
and there are a lot of them
pages and pages hundreds and hundreds
from the very first page you can see
that if you go there it's apparently
popular now to identify as an emoji
many of the pronouns aren't words at all
but pictures other pronouns include
poison poisons poisons and
poison self
i assume those are big pharma's pronouns
please respect them also fay fairy fair
fairies fairy self kitty kitty's kitty
self
stars star star self
and slows sloth's sloth self and on and
on
there's also dem demon demon's demon
self and if you're wondering what a self
identifying demon looks like
well you're in luck
hi my name is jasper i use that pronouns
hi my name is lyanna i use the demon
pronouns this video is how to use our
pronouns
so we're going to basically present
three sentences um one of them is going
to have one pronoun the other one's
going to have the other pronoun and then
the last one is going to have both
pronouns interchanged
so leona uses them pronouns in demon
pronouns so the first sentence would be
liana is my partner they are cute and i
am theirs i love them very much and i
hope they love themselves too
for the demon pronouns it would be leona
is my partner d miss q and i belong to
dean i love damon very much and i hope
dean loves demon self too
then interchanging the two would be
liana is my partner
they are cute and i am deans
i love demon very much
and i hope they love demon self too
she's she that she's going to be a
linguistics professor that's that's this
is what what this is what um grammar
teaching language and grammar that's
what that's what it's going to be pretty
soon and there is something very on the
nose about this in fact in the gospels
when jesus encountered demon-possessed
people
they would sometimes go by they them
pronouns because there was more than one
demon infesting the person and so we may
be able to draw some connections and
analogies here
but i'm afraid
that a lot of people on the same side of
the ideological spectrum might see this
sort of thing and make the same mistake
they made with gender ideology more
broadly assuming that it's kind of a
this weird and wacky phase and it's not
anything widespread or serious or worth
our attention
why why are we even paying attention
this is just tick tock who cares
and in saner times you know in a culture
that hadn't already sunk below the
surface and into the icy depths of
full-on insanity that would probably be
the right reaction after all demon self
over there
is really just a goth kid trying to be
edgy right we had those when i was a
teenager
the only difference is that now tiktok
exists so they have this unfortunate
vehicle to publicize and advertise these
embarrassing phases
except
that's not the only difference
the other difference and it's a big one
is that we now live in a society that
validates legitimizes and encourages
these alternative identities now when i
was a kid
the adults would tell the goth kids that
they were going through a phase they
need to snap out of it or they're never
going to be able to get a job or a
girlfriend
right that's what the adults used to say
to kids going through these kinds of
phases
now the adults stand off on the sideline
in cheerleader uniforms and pom-poms
sometimes literally
cheering the kids on in their delusions
would otherwise be a phase
what would be something that makes them
look back in a few years and cringe now
becomes an identity
the meaningless
is transformed into the meaningful
the effect is that a generation of kids
soon to be multiple generations
have been plunged into mass psychosis
we are not merely validating mental
illness but creating it
what would be a phase instead becomes
the kernel of a debilitating
lifelong identity crisis
and our culture is there with the water
cans making sure that those seeds are
germinated
there's not going to be any awakening
moment for these kids or at least there
need not be
i hope there is but there's nothing that
would
cause that to happen because we used to
say
well wait until you get into the real
world and that'll be a wake-up call
because the real world doesn't work like
this
but there is no real world anymore not
according to the people who run our
society
there is no reality
everything's subjective everything is
malleable
nothing is solid there's no firm ground
to stand on
mass psychosis
a generation driven into madness before
they're old enough to drive a car
that's what we're facing
nothing less
and i think we need to start treating
this like the
major problem that it clearly is
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen take a quick look
in the mirror you see those bags under
your eyes
they are disgusting you are disgusting
you can simply get rid of you can't do
anything about your whole face but you
can get rid of the bags under your eyes
at least and you should with genusell
plant stem cell therapy for bags and
puffiness under the eyes
as you know
this is something i've been sort of
gabbing about with my assistant tessa
for weeks now we're always talking about
genus cell serum by chamonix and in fact
i came in this morning and i saw her i
said well you've got some bags under the
eyes there have you used genusell today
she says i forgot to use it today what i
find is that women really appreciate it
when you point out physical flaws and
give them a method and a way to solve it
um and with its instant effects you'll
see results in as little as 12 hours
guaranteed all your money back plus for
new younger and wrinkle-free skin
chamonee will also give you the
legendary genusell xv wrinkle treatment
absolutely free just for trying genusell
today order now and save big on genusell
all packages are up to 50 off go to
genusell.com enter mat30 for an extra 30
off today that's geniuselle.com
genusell.com all right uh well if you're
watching the show you can see
if you're not you're missing out because
things are pretty festive in here in
just in time for halloween
[Music]
and uh before we left you know i was
talking to the production team and i
said uh i said yeah we could maybe put
maybe put a mask on the on the alien
back there something subtle
to acknowledge something subtle and
tasteful for halloween and then i come
back and there's just been a halloween
explosion in the studio but it looks
great and and now i think um somehow
we have the most festive
show on uh on the daily wire i don't
know how it worked out that way but it
did
um and also by the way different subject
but uh as you as you notice i am i am
actually physically here i'm not dead
much to the chagrin of many people out
there i know i was worried about that i
expressed my concerns after the whole
mishap with the plane we got stranded
had to get on uh allegiant
um an airline that uh that you know i
didn't i didn't know existed and uh
and you know not even a more like a
third rate airline
and
the engines are like hamster wheels you
know you actually everyone it was kind
of fun we all were sitting in there we
had our own pedals we had to keep
pedaling the whole time to keep the
engine running but we did make it home
and while i was on the plane i was in
the exit row and there's been this this
discussion the whole week about the
mystery of the exit row or maybe it was
only a mystery to me
but i ended up in the exit row again and
this time i actually did
i i worked up the courage to pick up the
pamphlet
and actually read what we're supposed to
do in the exit row
and now i know
that actually your responsibility is to
simply open the door and get out
that's it that's what so when they when
they say are you ready and able to help
in an emergency what they're really
saying is you get to be the first ones
out of this thing just open the door and
leave that's that's your whole that's
your responsibility
which is kind of nice um
but now it makes me feel less courageous
when i'm when i'm sitting there and that
we get the speech and then they ask the
question are you ready and willing to
help
and i can say yes i am here and now i
know that i'm really just volunteering
to be the only one who doesn't burn to
death
um i don't know why they don't upgrade i
don't know why they don't sell it well
they do sell an upgrade on the uh on the
exit row because of the the uh
the leg room but
i don't know why the the the the
airlines don't start selling upgrades
based on
you know who's mo least likely to die in
an accident depending on where you're
sitting in the plane
so you know if you want a 10
decreased risk of death then you could
sit here for a 45 upgrade
all right let's start with this uh from
joe biden he had a town hall with
anderson cooper
on cnn yesterday
and
a few bizarre moments that we come to
expect from from biden
but we're not going to worry about any
of that instead i want to play this here
he is talking about the vaccine mandates
and what led him to finally issue them
listen
as many as as one in three emergency
responders in some cities like chicago
los angeles right here in baltimore are
refusing to comply
with city vaccine mandates
i'm wondering where you stand on that
should police officers emergency
responders be mandated to get vaccines
and if not should they be
stay at home or let go yes and yes
by the way
by the way i waited until uh
july
to talk about mandating because i tried
everything else possible
the mandates are working
all the stuff about people leaving and
people goodness you have you have
everyone for united airlines to spirit
all these airlines we're not going to
get
all 96 97 of the people have gotten the
vaccine all the talk about all these
folks who are going to leave the
military if they're mandated not true
you got about a 90 some percent
vaccination rate i mean so there's a the
idea is that
look
the two things that concern me
one are those who just try to make this
a political issue freedom
i have the freedom to kill you
with my covey i mean come on freedom
number one number two
the second one is that uh you know the
the gross misinformation that's out
there
that is a truly horrifying clip it
really is
i know we're a little bit numb to it by
now but
the two things that happen in that clip
that
maybe maybe at
some point in the not too distant past
you would have would have been
unthinkable you couldn't have imagined
this
um
coming from a united states president
in public at a town hall maybe two
things number one he laughs at freedom
he has no
rebuttal to the freedom argument he says
yeah people are talking about freedom i
mean come on freedom
and he laughs and the end and the crowd
laughs
that that is his rebuttal to the freedom
argument is is simply to shrug it off
freedom who needs it
that's uh that's a that's a a la that's
that's a punchline freedom is a
punchline
to joe biden
and the brain dead seals clapping seals
in that audience
and then he also has an applause line
for firing police officers and first
responders
should police officers of first
responders be be fired yes
yeah get rid of them fire them
man we have come a long way down from in
in many ways but
this is one of the most pronounced you
think about
right after 9 11
everyone talks about how
united the country was in those uh in
those early days after 9 11 and much of
that was sort of
an illusion as we as we discovered
but another big thing and this lasted
for years it was kind of
celebrating first responders and police
officers and you know the people that
were there on the scene and
many of them died and sacrificed their
lives
um so we've gone from that in 20 years
to applau a united states president
talking about firing first responders
and it gets applause in the audience
and let's not overlook what he's saying
about the mandates which is hey i gave
you a chance
with your precious little freedom i gave
you a chance to do what i wanted you to
do and you didn't do it and i ran out of
patience and so i forced you to do it
things have gone very wrong in this
country
not only when
those sorts of policies can be put in
place
but when politicians feel comfortable
talking to us that way
and there have always been politicians
who
and presidents
who have
supported tyrannical policies have
wanted to uh abridge
and infringe upon our freedoms and so on
that that's always exit there are always
politicians like that
they're always there have always been
presidents like that the difference
though is that in times past
they would at least feel the need
to
uh use euphemisms
and to couch their infringement on
freedom in the language of freedom
to pull the bait and switch and there's
plenty of of baiting and switching going
on but when it comes to this to the
infringement of freedom they're at a
point now where they say well who needs
freedom
i gave you a chance you didn't do what i
wanted and so i'm gonna force you
the fact that they
feel comfortable talking to us that way
that means things have gone wrong with
us
we the people
that we tolerate this kind of attitude
this kind of language from politicians
who are supposed to be working for us
uh and
in that same vein here's a tweet from
joe biden which he put out uh yesterday
it says i ran for president for three
reasons
to restore the soul and decency of our
country
to rebuild our economy from the bottom
up
and the middle out
and to help unite our country
we're on the right track but there's
still work to be done now never mind the
fact that none of these things have
happened
and everything is is objectively
measurably worse now than it was when
biden took off it's it's real it's
impressive it's actually
exceeded
um
for many of us our worst expectations of
what joe biden could could uh could do
to this country in the span of less than
a year
i mean i didn't have a lot of hope i
expected
i i thought it would be bad but uh what
we're looking at right now in less than
a year
the the efficiency with which he's been
able to
uh destroy our countries that has been
impressive
but yeah never mind the fact that none
of this has happened rebuilding our
economy
the shelves at the grocery store are
empty
gas prices way up i mean it's people are
poorer now
living is more expensive
on and on
but even aside from that
i ran for president to restore the soul
and decency of our country
that's how so you
as one individual as a single
man you have the the this spiritual
ability to restore our soul and decency
and you want
if we're really you know if we really
want to prove that we're a decent
country
elect me
that means we're decent
we're not electing maybe that's just
plain indecent
once again politicians should not feel
comfortable talking this way
all right next we have attorney general
merrick garland he testified in front of
the house judiciary committee a number
of important subjects were covered and
we're going to play a few clips for you
but first here's garland explaining
why he sent the fbi after parents at
school boards well we already know the
claimed reason is that school boards
were under attack from violent parents
and there have been threats and there
have been all this kind of stuff
and the question being posed to him
is um well did you did you have
information do you actually have
intelligence suggesting
that this was a widespread problem of
violent parents and threats and
everything
uh where did you get this from and
here's what merrick garland says
first sentence of your memo very first
sentence you said in recent months
there's been a disturbing spike in
harassment intimidation threats of
violence yes when did you first review
the data showing this so-called
disturbing uptick
so i read the letter and we have been
seeing over time threats
i didn't ask you so you read the letter
that's that's your source so let me be
clear this is not a prosecution or is
there some study some effort some
investigation someone did that said
there's been a disturbing uptick or you
just take the words of the national
school board association
the national school board association
which represents thousands of school
boards and school board members says
that there are these kind of threats
when we read in the newspapers reports
of threats of violence when that is in
the context of threats of violence the
source for this for the very first line
in your in your mountain time of the
gentleman who's expired was the school
association letter fired mr deutch
amazing
not really amazing at all but but again
just in admitting it out loud so that's
the theme here
what information did he have no
information all he had and the reason
why he's sending the fbi after school
board
after uh parents and school board
meetings
is because he got a letter from the
school board association claiming that
this was happening and then also he read
it in the newspaper
this is the attorney general the united
states telling us that the newspaper
reports and one letter from the school
board association claiming that there
were all these threats was enough for
him to
mobilize the fbi to treat this like some
sort of um
national security emergency
well that only confirms what i've been
saying all along
which is that this is all this is this
is imaginary
there has been i mean if there were
actual examples
of real violence at school board
meetings merrick garland would have
mentioned those
would really help this case
but there's been basically none there's
been there has been essentially no
violence at school we're meetings the
one example that he knows he can't use
anymore
he certainly didn't want to bring this
up and give and give um
give his interrogators a chance to
to talk about it but the one example was
scott smith louden county
who wasn't even violent but he got upset
because his daughter had been raped in a
loudoun county school and they were
lying to his face about it
that's the one example of violence which
wasn't even violence
that's out the window now they can't
talk about that now
and so what else is there nothing
there have been parents raising their
voices at that's what's happened
and i will admit that that's true there
have been a lot i've i have been one of
them i have done it myself
there have been a lot of us at school
were meetings raising our voices and
yelling a little bit
and that's why we need the fbi to
investigate
as far as the threats i mean i again if
he had if he had actual information if
he had looked into this himself if the
fbi looked into it and they had found
that there are actually you know
hundreds or even dozens of examples
of serious death threats against school
board members then he would have told us
that
the fact that he doesn't is is you know
that that that tells us what we need to
know
i mean i said from the beginning i don't
buy it i'm sorry
these school these all these school
board members say i'm getting death
threats
i don't i i don't believe you
there may there may be a few cases where
it actually has happened
that's more than possible
it's happened to me many times
so i certainly know that there are
people out there who will send death
threats
but i'm not just i'm not going to take
your word for it i don't take your word
for it i don't believe you unless you
prove it
uh because you you have a
there could be a very obvious ulterior
motive in claiming that you are getting
death threats and playing the victim
since that means i just can't take your
word for it show it show us
that wasn't the only important subject
that was brought up though um there's
also this congressman
massey confronted merrick garland
about january 6th and specifically the
question about whether there were feds
in the crowd
deliberately instigating the crowd to
enter
the capitol building we know that this
is something that um
they'll the feds like to do
they like to encourage people to commit
crimes so that they can then prosecute
those crimes
and he played a video which i guess
we'll play this video first uh the video
features some guy
um over the course of you know more than
a day
down in dc like in the night leading up
to january 6th on the the night of
january 5th and then on january 6th
there's this one guy
who is all over the place trying to
convince the crowd to go into the
capitol
and you also know when we play this
video how does the crowd react
you know they're they don't want to but
this one guy is saying let's do it even
if we get arrested
um and there's a there's a theory online
i mean i don't know who this guy is but
the theory is among some people i think
a pretty credible one is that this guy's
a federal agent or an asset um
this is the video that thomas matt that
congressman massey played for america
let's play the video first here it is
i know in fact tomorrow
i don't even like to say it because i'll
be arrested
we need
[Music]
we need to go into the capitol
into the campus
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
speaking we go to the capitol the
capitol is this direction
okay so you see there uh
one guy who has not been i don't think
he's been officially identified
but what we know is that he has not been
um
that guy who's on camera
all over the place saying let's go to
the capitol even if we get arrested like
acknowledging
that he knows it's a crime
trying to get the crowd to do it he
hasn't been arrested and charged with
anything yet
some of the other people in fact some of
the people in the crowd who were saying
no and calling him a fed they've been
arrested and charged but not him
what does that tell you well that was
the question that congressman massey had
for merrick garland let's listen to that
all right you have you have those images
there and they're captioned
uh they were from january 5th and
january 6th
as far as we can determine the
individual who was saying he'll probably
go to jail he'll probably be arrested
but he wants every but they need to go
into the capitol the next day is then
the next day directing people to the
capitol and as far as we can find this
individual has not been charged with
anything you said this is one of the
most sweeping investigations in history
have you seen that video or
those frames from that video
so as i um
said at the outset one of the norms of
the justice department is to not comment
on impending investigations and
particularly not to comment about
particular scenes or particular
individuals this without i was hoping
today to give you an opportunity to put
to rest
the concerns that people have that there
were federal agents or assets of the
federal government present on january
5th and january 6th can you tell us
without talking about particular
incidents or particular videos how many
agents are assets of the federal
government were present on january 6
whether they agitated to go into the
capital and if any of them did so i'm
not going to violate this norm of
of of the rule of law i'm not going to
comment on an investigation that's
ongoing
so that's a yes um that's a yes because
if the answer was no if there were no
federal agents trying to rally the crowd
up rile the crowd up
then he would have no problem saying no
of course i didn't have what are you
talking about
there's no reason the i'm not gonna
violate the rule of law the rule of law
says you can't
if there were no federal agents in that
crowd you the rule of law says you can't
tell us that
what law is that exactly
pretty clear pretty clear what happened
here um
you know a giant
setup
and now they're arresting you know the
guy with the buffalo hat or the guy who
took a
the the podium and walked out with it
every time i see merrick garland he is
the the you know if you were to look up
the term banality of evil in the
dictionary you would see merrick garland
this kind of
empty
dull
[Music]
you know emo just straight faced
emotionless person
nothing immediately uh objectionable
about them but then you listen to what
he's saying
and what he's doing
and it becomes clear and also by the way
congressman massey there
um bringing up a very important point
getting the chance here to cross-examine
the the attorney general
congressman massey is
and you know how i feel about
politicians in general and about
republicans i'm not a big fan of
very many of them
[Music]
i'm pretty harsh on on all of them
it takes a lot for me to be impressed
by a politician but congressman massey
is one of the few good ones i don't
agree with him he's more he's more
libertarian than i am so i don't agree
with him on every single issue but
he's a talented and skilled politician
um
and uh and uh a a
a real valuable defender of the
conservative cause
and someone who's actually trying to to
root out corruption
in dc
and putting his own career and
reputation on the line and doing so
he's a valuable one he's one we need
and he's also one and you might not want
to hear this but he's he's one
trump when he was in office tried to run
massey out of town
trump tried to get massey
out of office
because what did congressman massey do
wrong well he just he wasn't
person he didn't show enough personal
deference to donald trump as an
individual
and that's why trump hated massey and
wanted him gone
even though he's one of the best
republicans we have in congress one of
the few good ones trump wanted him out
because trump's
flaw as a leader his biggest flaw and
this is important to remember as we get
into 2024
his biggest flaw as a leader his fatal
flaw
is that for him when it comes to hiring
people and deciding who to elevate and
who to support the number one
qualification as far as trump is
concerned is is how they feel about him
personally
which means that a lot of really he
tried to run a lot of really talented
and valuable conservatives out of town
while hiring a lot of establishments
swamp snakes and rats because they
flattered him
as a fatal leadership flaw
i mean you have to be able to recognize
the talent and value of people even the
ones who don't personally like you that
much
you have to be able to set that aside
especially when we've got a country to
save here
something to keep in mind um
and that is a flaw that as far as we can
tell
ron desantis does not share
which is why it's desantis 2024 all the
way as far as i'm concerned all right
this is from fox news uh big big update
on a story that many people have been
following
the fbi on thursday confirmed confirmed
that remains recovered from
a a nature preserve or park in florida
on wednesday
were
florida fugitive brian laundries the
comparison of dental records confirmed
the 23 year old's identity according to
fbi
laundry's former fiancee gabby petito
turned up dead near a wyoming campsite
the couple shared in late august
and now and of course as you know
there's there's been this
manhunt that's been going on for weeks
and finally they recovered remains and
they belong to brian laundry i guess we
still don't know
exactly what happened to them they're
gonna do you know they'll do the um
uh
autopsy and all that kind of stuff and
they'll they'll figure that out seems
was this he that he committed suicide or
did something else happen to him was he
attacked by alligators i mean who knows
um i i will say though and i haven't
followed this story very closely
um but
you know the news yesterday was that the
the fbi they were going to brian
laundry's house to let
his parents know that they had recovered
the remains of their son
and so you know their son was is dead
and
i i hear that
and i i do feel
a fair amount of sympathy for brian
laundry's family and for his parents
um what i what i don't quite
understand is in the media and online
just the the incredible amount of venom
that's been directed at the parents of
brian laundry
i don't quite understand that
it's
i'm not i'm not even the most
sympathetic guy in the world
so if i if you if you discover that i'm
being more sympathetic than you about
something
then you need to look at yourself in the
mirror because that shouldn't be the way
the way it works
so i feel sympathy for the parents i i
don't understand they they they have
been turned into public enemy number one
they've they've been
the media has has been camped out of
their house for weeks following them
everywhere
everyone hates them i don't
you and i don't quite get it unless
there's some sort of theory that they
were involved uh somehow
in the killing of gabby potato well if
that was the case and that would change
my
then my sympathy would go out the window
but i don't think there's any indication
of that i don't think that's even a
theory that's on the table
it's not their fault
i guess there's this this inclination
when someone does something horrible to
blame the parents and to say well you
obviously went uh something went
terribly wrong the way you raised this
person and that could be the case but
not necessarily
you know we raise our kids and this is
something that we as parents we remain
very cognizant of and it's something
that keeps us up at night sometimes
it's just the reality that our kids are
are human beings and um with their own
conscious
life and and uh
and their own will and everything and
they make their and they can make their
own choices
and so
what keeps you up at night is the
realization that
you could raise your children perfectly
i mean you could do everything
right
or almost i mean no one can do
everything right but you could do almost
everything right
and and you could love your kids and do
what you think is best for them
and instill in them the proper moral
values
and they could still go out into the
world and become horrible monstrous
people and do terrible things
that could still happen
because they still have free will
and when it does it's not fair to put
that on the parents
and now you think about
the situation the parents are in
their child is a killer
and now he's dead
so they've got guilt as as well as
mourning and they probably feel that
they can't really mourn their son in the
normal way like they don't have the
right to because of this horrible thing
he did
and uh
i don't know it's just it's the worst
thing in the world uh you know as a
parent i mean you would think the worst
thing in the world as a parent is to
lose your child and that is the worst
thing in the world
but um
one degree even worse than that
is when you sort of lose your child
spiritually
and and you lose your child's soul
because they commit some hideous evil
act and then they die
and that's um it's just unthinkable as a
parent it's like that's that is the
ultimate nightmare
i i would much rather be dead than have
that happen to my kids or have my kids i
would choose death over that in a second
it's the worst thing and so
i do feel some sympathy for them i don't
really understand why others don't but
okay what else do we got here
here's someone else i have sympathy for
okay this is this is uh this is the
sympathy show this is the show
things are good we got the halloween
decorations things are a little bit
topsy-turvy and bizarre and so i have
sympathy for this person also
a teacher in riverside california
has been suspended for insensitivity to
native americans and this stems from
an incident in class where she was
apparently trying to teach the kids
a mnemonic device for trigonometry
sohcahtoa
um which is something
i'm not going to try to get it i could
explain it to you because i'm i'm a
trigonometry expert i'm a bit of a
mathematician myself i'm not going to
explain because you probably wouldn't
understand
but it's a mnemonic device it's supposed
to help with trigonometry
and this was her method of kind of
ingrain you know drilling that into the
kids heads let's let's watch this
oh
oh
and i get all of my feathers
[Music]
[Music]
okay so listen
that's
that's not the method i would choose if
for some reason i was hired to teach
trigonometry
uh to high school kids
i probably wouldn't do that but
in her defense
you will never forget sokatoa
will you you will remember i don't even
know what it is but but i will always
remember sokatoa
and it does kind of sound like an indian
chief doesn't it
so this is what it's about it's finding
outside the box thinking of ways to get
kids to
remember the material and so i'm going
to defend her on that basis but
unfortunately she has been suspended and
not even it's not it's not that she's
been suspended because
it's suspected that she had a mental
breakdown in the middle of class uh no
it's because of insensitivity to native
americans here's the statement from
the riverside unified school district it
says a recording of one of our teachers
has been widely circulated on social
media
these behaviors are completely
unacceptable and an offensive depiction
of the vast and expansive native
american cultures and practices
her actions do not represent the values
of our district
the teacher has been placed on leave
while the district conducts an
investigation
um
and this was originally i think this
this
video was recorded by a native american
student
who according to the person who posted
it initially
felt that this performance by the
teacher was an act of violence
against him
now you could say there was an act of
violence against all of our eardrums in
a certain way
but of course the idea the idea that
this is uh somehow offensive to native
americans
is is absurd
it was supposed to just be a silly way
of getting kids to
to remember it and they will
none of those kids
none of those kids will ever forget
sokatoa
they might forget everything else
they've learned in school they won't
forget that
and she's suspended for it i i
personally find it
uh outrageous
all right let's read the comments
who's rocking polka dot and flannel
shirts without shame
do you know their name
they're the sweet baby gang
uh oh yeah before we read the comments i
almost forgot about this also this is
from a tweet from the dcist
news organization that covers
news in dc and there's a picture there
of the uh of the capital of dc
and uh drowned by by water
and it says imagine seeing the lincoln
memorial surrounded by churning potomac
waters or only being able to access the
pentagon by boat
this is what dc might look like if the
world continues its current greenhouse
gas emission levels
and i saw this and i thought well that's
that's um
wow that's incredible and
that's why i decided to leave my car
idling all day while i'm at work
i mean you're telling me another benefit
of global global warming
is that we get to wash dc into the sea
without drowning washington dc that's
that's supposed to be a what a downside
it also looks kind of fun i mean imagine
that you you gotta
you take a little boat a little ferry to
get to the um lincoln memorial island
there
looks fun okay
this is from sweet mama g says i would
rather hitchhike with a sign that says
i'm an orphan no one will look for me
than fly allegiant also michelle fiori
was my assembly woman in vegas she
actually would make a great governor she
was on the front lines with the bundy
ranch if you remember that
she opposed harry reid's ban on raw milk
because his son got a tummy ache from it
and she often holds open houses at her
house for the community to have
discussions about local issues
she's extremely involved with the
community in vegas
um
i'll take your word for it i don't know
like i said i don't know anything about
her
um it's just a bad it's a it's a it's a
bad ad is my point it's a very bad
advertisement for a politician
because what you're telling me about her
is that
she's a serious person
who has achieved
real things
and um is a is a is a real asset for the
conservative cause and
for the people of nevada that's what
you're saying
but i didn't that's not what i got from
the advertisement
what i got from the advertisement is
that this is a
ridiculous shallow person
who has nothing to say other than the
most basic and stereotypical talking
points
so
not a good ad
uh
this is from ferror's dragon
matt's pivoting between i'm always i'm
always right my opinion should be iron
law for all men
and my podcast is a pathetic waste of
time
really throws me off balance
well i don't see why i can't be both
isn't it possible that i'm always right
and my podcast is a pathetic waste of
time
i think it is
that's what i'm going with that's how i
thread that needle
um
sean says as someone whose job it is to
work on airplanes i can tell you matt
that this actually is very common a lot
of technology in airplanes is about as
old as an n64
and turning it off and on again usually
does solve most of the problems
if something breaks it only needs to
work once for someone to
sign it off as fixed
was this supposed to make me feel better
about flying
it probably wasn't you're trying to this
this is what you think i need in my life
is more anxiety
so something's broken and then it works
once and then they say well let's take
it up 35 000 feet
see if this holds
sean you're banned from the show
i blame you for this
um joshua says hey matt huge fan quick
question
[Music]
how would you persuade your fiance into
taking your last name for marriage if
she were opposed to doing so
should it be a deal breaker or red flag
if she doesn't
love the show almost as much as you love
advertising your sponsors
well then you must really really love it
and
is it a deal breaker if your fiance
doesn't want to take your last name
[Music]
uh yes
it it is a deal breaker
um
it's it is a red flag it's beyond a red
flag it's a deal breaker i would say
because
the whole point as when you get married
is that now you are
becoming one you're becoming unified
one family
and so if you're planning on marrying a
woman and she's saying i don't want to
take your name
what she's saying is i don't want to be
completely unified to you
i don't really want to be one family
unit
you know i i want to maintain
this division i want there to be this
sort of line that separates us
a name is not a small thing
as as human beings
and having a last name as a family it's
one of the things that ties you together
that identifies you
as a family as a family unit
not multiple little units
okay as a family you want to be one unit
a home not like an apartment complex
where you're all in the same building
but you've got different your own little
units and your own little um
separate lives divided by walls and
everything
so yeah i would say that that's uh
that's a deal-breaker
doesn't mean you can't marry her but it
should be like this isn't happening
unless unless
you you agree that we're going to have
we're going to share a name we're going
to be one family
i mean i would say the same about if if
i was getting ready to marry somebody
and they said they want to have
different bank accounts
and bank accounts aren't even as
profoundly important as names
but once again that that to me shows
that you want to maintain divisions
you don't really want to be unified you
don't want to become as one you want to
be two separate people have your own
account
your own uh you know
and so i i would see that also as a as a
deal breaker
um
claire says matt how come you don't just
bring your my pillow with you when you
travel
you talk about how bad you miss it when
you're away from home so wouldn't it
just make sense to take it with you
well because i'm a man and men don't
travel with pillows that's my let's say
my wife does that my
this is why anytime we go somewhere in a
car we go on a like a week vacation
and and
half of the car is packed to the brim
with pillows because all the kids and my
wife they got to bring their own fluffy
everything
men don't do that
even though i miss my my pillow dearly
but it just makes it all the sweeter
when i when i finally get home to it
well maybe you heard the news that uh
disney has ousted one of their talented
sports reporters from espn named allison
williams allison is a college football
and basketball reporter who had been
with espn since 2011 until she announced
her resignation yesterday why well
because disney espn's parent company is
forcing its employees to receive the
kova 19 vaccine or face termination and
allison chose to wait while she tries to
have a child sure the cdc claims the
vaccines are safe for pregnant women but
is it the cdc's choice to make or is it
allison's
it's wrong to force americans to choose
between their livelihood and their
freedom to make personal medical
decisions we started the daily wire to
fight the lab to protect our rights so
we're excited to announce that we have
signed allison williams to lead a very
special sports series exclusively for
our members more details to come later
here at the daily wire leftist elites
don't dictate our content you do you
decide what to watch and which creators
to support and if you want premium
entertainment and sports content without
the woke then become a member at
dailywire.com subscribe and use code do
not comply at checkout for 25 percent
off off and also the truth is hard to
come by if you're listening to the
legacy media which is why we've taken
matters into our own hands with our
newest morning podcast morning wire not
only has it been topping the apple and
spotify chart since the release it's the
only daily podcast that values your time
and the truth and while we're working
overtime to bring you the news and get
it all the way up to number one we need
your help as well as well so subscribe
and start listening to morning wire on
apple spotify or wherever you listen to
podcasts and leave a five star review if
you like what you hear now let's get to
our daily cancellation
[Music]
so today i have a somewhat belated
reverse cancellation earlier in the week
i said that two men should not be
allowed to adopt babies just as two
women shouldn't be allowed to adopt
babies either and i don't think single
people should be allowed to adopt babies
by the way i believe that every baby
deserves and needs both a mom and a dad
and that's what the law should stipulate
now as you may recall this all came up
during the paternity leave debate you
may also recall that when i made that
statement about gay adoption
i predicted that media matters would try
to hit me for it and mere hours later my
prophecy was fulfilled the left-wing
activist group pulled the clip posted it
to their site and their social media
pages and soon some lgbt news sites had
picked it up as well
um you know i just sort of ignored them
and the outrage fizzled out in about 12
hours and that's what happens with most
outrage when it's ignored as much as i
love to intentionally antagonize my
cancelers i have to say there's
something especially satisfying and also
hilarious about allowing them to scream
impotently into the void while you go
about your day as if they don't exist
i should probably adopt that gratifying
approach more often than i do
the problem is that i just enjoy arguing
too much
and that's why i can't let this week end
without circling back vasaki style to
say a few more things
on this topic now
to help frame this discussion we'll use
the hit piece published by the gay news
site lgbtq nation
and it says quote matt walsh a
right-wing blowhard with the
conservative website the daily wire has
criticized transportation secretary p
buddhist for taking paternity leave to
help his husband raise their adopted
newborn twins walsh said that it was
absurd a luxury for public employees
like bootage to receive two months off
to care for their children on the
taxpayer dime because the us is deeply
in debt and facing a transportation
crisis
but then he showed his true concern
gays raising kids
while she said quote babies need their
mothers which is why two two men
shouldn't be allowed to adopt babies in
the first place
um repeating a decades-old
anti-lgbtq line that every child
deserves a mother and a father
he continued the outrage mob can now
start a secondary campaign over that
comment but i'll say it again two men
should not be allowed to adopt babies
because babies need mothers and fathers
mother need mothers they also need
fathers which is why two women shouldn't
be allowed either
not only is walsh repeating lies used by
anti-lgbt organizations around the world
but he's also wrong numerous studies
have shown that same-sex couples raise
children just as healthy as mixed gender
parents also he's inadvertently arguing
that single parents shouldn't be allowed
to raise kids either
no i'm not
i'm saying single parents shouldn't be
allowed to adopt kids
and there's nothing inadvertent about
that
the article goes on for a little while
longer before finishing with this
as for walsh he recently rented a home
in loudoun county virginia just so we
could speak against the county school
district's pro-transgender transgender
student policies so it's hardly
surprising to hear anti-lgbt speaking
points dribbling out of his mouth
now i take exception to this
talking points don't dribble out of my
mouth
i think a term like spewed or spouted or
ejected or disgorged would be more
appropriate
and aside from that i think there are a
few more important points to be made on
this topic of gay adoption
the first is that advocates for gay
adoption will always assure us
that studies have vindicated their
position you heard it again in the
article i just read people these days
they think that any discussion can be
ended
any argument can be won by quickly
scanning google for a study
that allegedly supports whatever
preconceived notion they have in their
head
what they don't bother doing what nobody
ever seems to do is actually read the
studies they cite
and that's a problem because as it turns
out literally anyone can do a study and
engineer it to prove literally any
proposition
there are no laws governing how studies
are conducted or what methods have to be
used
i could go out right now and conduct a
study to prove that pigs can fly
but you'd have to read the study to find
out that when i say pigs can fly what i
really mean is that if you launch them
from a catapult they'll travel through
the air a certain distance before
splattering all over the ground
the point is that methodology is
important
methodology matters
and so when you actually take the time
to read the studies that are cited in
support of gay adoption
what you'll find is that the methodology
is almost as ludicrous and arbitrary as
hurling pigs through the air with a
catapult
for one thing
most of the studies rely on
self-reported data from the parents
okay so the researchers ask gay parents
how their kids are doing emotionally how
they're doing psychologically and so on
and this is obviously going to lead to
some biased answers especially because
oftentimes these are not blind studies
the participants know that the
researchers are studying gay parenting
which means they have a vested interest
in giving a certain answer
which means they're probably not going
to say oh gee my kids are doing pretty
poorly i think i'm really screwing them
up
furthermore these studies don't pull
from random and representative samples
of the population
many of the studies focus on high-income
lesbian mothers who can afford ivf
treatments
the sample sizes along with being not
random not representative and not blind
are also very small most of the time
and then there's perhaps the biggest
problem of all
to claim that children do not suffer any
detrimental effects from being raised by
same-sex parents you would need to track
a very large
socioeconomically diverse sample size
for a long period of time
as parents
we don't really know how our parenting
has panned out until our kids are adults
but gay adoption has not been legal and
widespread enough for long enough to
have that kind of data
so it's the same thing you run into when
lgbt activists claim that puberty
blockers don't cause any long-term ill
effects in kids well how could they
possibly know that
we didn't start dosing large numbers of
physically healthy kids with this stuff
until the last few years
you're just assuming it won't cause
long-term damage you believe it won't
you want us to believe it won't
but you don't know that because you
can't know it
this is why we must use other resources
aside from academic studies to parse
this question resources like common
sense
resources like the history of the human
race
precedent
also biological science
so taking all those things into account
here's what we can say
all children
have a mother and a father
that's how nature set it up
now i believe and nearly everybody in
the entire world everywhere believed
until 12 seconds ago that the mother and
father roles are important and distinct
and not expendable
children need both parents
some children will be deprived of what
they need because of death or divorce
but the point is that it is a
deprivation
they can survive it they might even
thrive in spite of it but it will be in
spite of it
every child should be raised by a mother
and a father
the cruel reality of life is that not
every child will have that even though
they should have it but as a society we
should do what we can to ensure that as
many children have it as possible
as it happens there are millions of
man-woman couples waiting in line to
adopt babies as we speak every baby
could go to a loving home and be given
the gift of a mother and a father
there's no good reason to deprive them
of that gift
the only reason is that some gay couples
want to adopt and it would cause them
emotional pain
if they were prohibited from doing so my
contention is that the needs of the
child should come before the emotional
desires of the adults in this case
so let's flip this around
if you're a proponent of same-sex
adoption
you clearly believe that either the
mother or the father role or both are
expendable
in taking that position
you are asserting something that is
radically contrary to everything we've
observed as human beings through the
course of human civilization you are
making an extreme claim
i would even say a bigoted claim because
you are ruthlessly negating the value
and importance of mothers and fathers
the burden of proof in this situation
falls on you
but of course the only way to prove that
mothers and fathers really are
expendable as you believe is to forge
ahead as though they are and then check
back in 50 years to see if to see if
you're right
that is in fact the course we've chosen
in our society
we've chosen through this issue and many
others
to treat kids as lab rats
to to take them
and verge off in a radically different
direction
and give them a life and an existence
and a world
that is totally severed
from the life existence in world that
all of the rest of us lived in
and we're just gonna do this
and see if it works
um it won't
and there's no good reason to try
and that's the point
and that's why
uh i must take these i must resurrect
this cancellation attempt of me and uh
and
say to the cancelers that no in fact you
are cancelled
and that'll do it for us today and for
the week
have a great weekend
thanks for listening godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover our technical director is austin
stevens
production manager pavel vadasky the
show is edited by ali hinkle
our audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair makeup is done by cherokee heart
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matte wall show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 21.
hey everybody this is andrew clavin host
of the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
republic is collapsing the end of days
is approaching and the moons turn to
blood but on the andrew clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the fall
of the republic with me andrew clavin